when typhoon tip reached its peak
intensity on October 12th 1979 in the
West Pacific it became the most powerful
storm ever recorded it's wind speeds
peaked at 305 km/h gale force winds
extended from its Center in a radius of
a thousand kilometers making it the
biggest hurricane or typhoon ever
recorded and it was nothing compared to
the storm which is tearing the sky apart
over my head right now to understand
that storm and why it's going to bring
freezing temperatures to much of the
northern hemisphere first we need to
backtrack a little bit and talk about
how we divide the atmosphere into layers
typhoon tip like all storms we
experienced was trapped in the bottom
layer of the atmosphere what we call the
troposphere we divide the atmosphere
into layers depending on how the air
temperature changes as you go higher and
higher up place to the ground if you go
higher up the air temperature decreases
it gets colder this is the troposphere
but when you get to about 10 kilometers
above the surface this breaks down and
as you go higher the air temperature
stays about the same and then if you
keep going higher the temperature
actually increases this is the
stratosphere the air here is much
thinner than in the troposphere but it's
much bigger it's huge it stretches from
10 kilometers up to about 50 kilometers
up all over the earth and it's home to
the most powerful storm in the world the
stratospheric polar vortex the polar
vortex exists because every year the
Earth's winter pole doesn't receive any
sunlight making it extremely cold
well the equator is still very warm and
that difference in temperature drives a
huge circulation in the stratosphere air
starts to rotate around the pole forming
a circulation that's about 6,000
kilometers across this thing is the size
of a continent and it moves quick the
typical wind speed of the vortex which
forms in the northern hemisphere is over
200 kilometres per hour but it peaks at
well over 400
km/h making it way faster than any
typhoon or hurricane and the vortex
which forms in the southern hemisphere
is even stronger with a typical wind
speed of over 300 km/h now you'd expect
a donor of air the size of Asia rotating
at 200 or 300 kilometres an hour to be
pretty strong and stable and most of the
time that's true it forms every single
year and it dominates the circulation in
the middle atmosphere but every now and
again about six times every decade it
spectacularly falls apart like it's
doing right now starting on about the
9th of February the normally pretty
strong and coherent polar vortex started
to deform and tear itself apart
splitting in two
instead of having one giant rotating
massive area of a head this is getting
out of hand now there are two of them
this event is known as a sudden
stratospheric warming and the one that's
happening over my head right now is
gonna influence weather across the
northern hemisphere for the next month
or two now I'll get to how in just a
second but first you might think because
it's called a warming that it's gonna
make us warmer at the surface but
actually it's the exact opposite the
sheer violence of the circulation
splitting apart causes the air over the
pole to get squished down towards the
surface and that compression results in
significant heating to put just how much
heating into perspective the room that
you're sat in right now is probably
about 20 degrees Celsius or 70 freedom'
units if I were to increase the
temperature in your room by saved 10
degrees Celsius then you definitely
notice it it would be going from room
temperature to shorts and t-shirt
weather like summer here in the UK if I
was to increase it by 20 degrees Celsius
then it will go for being room
temperature to an Australian summer
while if I increased it by 30 degrees
Celsius it would be more like the very
hottest part of the Middle East but when
the vortex splits apart the air in the
stratosphere doesn't warm up by 10 or 20
or 30 degrees Celsius
it warms by 50 or 60 or 70 or even 80
degrees Celsius and as the name suggests
this happens quickly in a matter of days
imagine your room going from Siberia in
winter to the Sahara in summer in less
than a week and this very month part of
the polar atmosphere have warmed by over
70 degrees Celsius in less than a week
now remember this is happening about 40
or 50 kilometres up where there's less
than 1% as thick as it is at the surface
and yet these events are so violent
possibly the most violent events in the
whole atmosphere that they still have an
influence a very real influence on the
weather that we experience for about two
months after a sudden warming happens we
see that storms tracking the way across
the Atlantic are deflected further south
and freezing cold air that's normally
held over the Arctic by the strength of
the polar vortex is able to penetrate
further south and spill towards the
equator bringing extremely cold weather
research actually co-authored by my PhD
supervisor has shown that in the
aftermath of sudden warming's there's an
increase in extreme cold and we can
expect something similar to happen over
the coming weeks why this happens is
something of an unanswered question that
my PhD thesis actually tackled there are
different theories to explain the
downward implements of the polar vortex
including waves being reflected off the
bottom of the vortex new circulations
being created by the wave breaking and
far-field effects of the vortex itself
my thesis for what it's worth looked at
the last one of those and found that
there's a subtlety in how the polar
vortex interacts with the troposphere
and the surface basically the surface is
only affected by the polar vortex
if the troposphere is willing to accept
it's in a configuration to accept that
influence but this is an active area of
research at the moment there are so many
questions that still unanswered like
what's the mechanism that
next the stratosphere in the troposphere
how can we use knowledge of that
mechanism to improve surface forecasts
and how is that interaction gonna change
with a warming climber for the time
being we do understand the basics the
vortex splitting apart will probably
make its influence felt on the surface
around about now and that influence will
stick around for a couple of weeks
arctic air is going to be finding a new
home
further south after that the vortex will
gradually reform in the stratosphere and
the atmosphere will go back to something
approaching normal but if you're going
through a cold spell in the northern
hemisphere right now you might be able
to blame the most powerful storm in the
world splitting the sky apart if the
idea of these big unanswered research
questions has whet your appetite and
you're interested in following in my
footsteps and researching the atmosphere
then a great place to get started is
brilliant org in particular they're out
in nature course is full of problems
about how physics influences the natural
environment in my opinion learning
science is all about applying concepts
that you've learned to practice problems
and then if you get those problems wrong
identifying your misconceptions now this
is exactly what brilliant is all about
it gives you a bunch of practice
problems and so it helps you identify
your misconceptions and then crucially
it helps you correct your understanding
so if you want to have a go at this and
look through some physics problems go to
brilliant org forward slash Simon Clark
and the first 200 people to click on
that link will also get 20% off their
premium annual subscription if you would
like to learn more about the subject
matter of this video then consider
checking out some of the videos I made
during my PhD on the subject and if
you'd like to learn more about how I
made the visualizations in this video
well I didn't they all came from Earth
mill school Nets
a free website which is updated every
day with current atmosphere and ocean
data I highly recommend you go and have
a look how to play super easy to use and
it shows how amazing the world around us
three years